louisville police shot and killed
brianna taylor the deadly shooting of
philando castilla stephon clark killed
by police 50 shots six officers opened
fire
around the united states
enough is enough but it's been enough
yeah
i got a story to tell black communities
have a deep rooted fear of being treated
unfairly by police a black man that's
why the odds are being pulled over
compared to a white man to say i can't
breathe it's not as though he didn't try
to communicate you're just like a lion
what is it gonna take i'm mad as hell
but we got the keys i promise you
today's political climate has carried on
the tradition of protecting those who
have been accused of excessive use of
force don't be too nice yeah i hope it's
on the way
i'll tell you what freedom is to me no
fear no restraint yeah there have been
more protests than the whole last period
of civil rights
it's not enough to just watch it and be
upset about it
we have to come up with a solution
we look at what the community is asking
of
us what do we have to lose
by actually doing something different
you